hidden in the back room of an Italian
church is the classiest st. relic in all
of Europe so in 2006 my wife and I were
traveling in Italy and we went to
bolonia because we had a saint relic
that we really wanted to see us we went
at it belonging at church not to be
confused with the Bologna Church which
is not a thing we walked in and we we
couldn't we couldn't figure out where
the same relic was but as we were
leaving we saw that there was a little
doorbell my wife rang the bell and after
a minute the door creaked open we walked
in and suddenly we were face-to-face
with st. Catherine of Bologna
she is a 500 year old mummified nun
sitting in a golden throne relics are
basically a bit of st. phone or hair or
even a skull relics were the were the
pop stars of their day they had people
who were desperate to touch them the
Saint relics would be carried on
processions and just mobbed it was a big
deal
catherine was a talented young woman she
was a painter he played the violin
beautifully because of this she is the
patron saint of artists she's also
responsible for some small miracles as
she's said to have left some bread in
the oven forgotten about it and come
back an hour later and the bread hadn't
burned a nun stubbed her toe and say
Catherine said a prayer and the toe was
healed so you know he said these are
like you know these are small miracles
but thank God for small miracles right
so a few weeks after she died she was
dug up and this was common with very
important figures in the Catholic Church
so they took her out they said that she
was flexible intact and sweet-smelling
if their body was shown not to be
decomposing as quickly as would be
expected they were considered
incorruptible that the grace of God had
literally stopped them from decomposing
one of the the nuns had a vision of her
on
and throne which is when they placed her
into the room where she is now and has
been for almost the last 500 years
subscribe here and watch more videos
here so actually there are there are
there three different classes of holy
relics others Class A which is like a
part of the saint like literally like
you know I don't then there's Class B
relics which are something that the same
war or touched so in Class C relic is
just something that touched a class a
relic so like next time I mean turn to
this but if you were to be next to a
class a relic and for some reason it
wasn't sealed up in some kind of
beautiful ornate reliquary and you like
just touched it I think then you're a
classy relic god we really like to keep
bits of people like we even in science
like Galileo Einstein all of the
communist leaders are mummified the
communism and science are secular
institutions and we still can't get over
the need to like hang on to the to the
dead to the powerful dead we want to
keep them